- Madame Zourabichvili, bonsoir.
Merci d'être
- D'abord, quel est votre
sentiment, quandent, quandent, z
les combats qui se poursuivent,
en Ukraine, pour une troisièmet,
les civils qui fuient,
oupes russes qui sont
aux portes de Kiev?
SALOMÉ ZOURABICHVILI,
présidente de la Géorgie
- D'abord, c'est un sentiment
de déjà-vu, puisque pour nous
par la Russie, ce n'est pas une
nouveauté. Nous avons vécuavonsa
dans l'histoire plusieurs fois :
au début du siècle dern
quand la premiègéorgienne, comm,
a été ensuite renversée panversr
les armées rouges. Et ensuite,le
de 91, séparatistes
ont été utilisés contreet enfin,
nous a guerre de 2008,
qui précède un petit peu
le conflit que l'on voit
aujour
- Hmm-hmm!
- Donc, c'est du déjà-vu,
et en
très grande admiration pour
l'extraordinaire résistance
du peuple ukrainien, qui est
réellement jamais vue.
- Oui.
- Cette organisation face
au départ à tout le monde comme
une agression totale à laquelle
personne ne peut résister etques
jours, et en réalité, on voit,
au bout de trois semaines,s fort
en quelque sorte équilibrées,es,
que la superpuissance militaires
si superpuissance que ça,
et que l'infériorité ukrainienne
est aujourd'hui compensée
par l'extrême détermination
de défendre son pays.
- Mais à quel prix, non,
toute cette destruction?
- Ah, mais le prix, il n'a pas
été choisi par l'Ukraine.
son territoire, son pays,
ce qui est quelque chose
que l'on connaît, et c'est ça
une volonté de survivre
et de faire survivre sa propre
liberté, et d'ailleurs,
Je dois dire que nous, nous
consid
aujourd'hui se battent aussi
pour ne battent aussi
pour l'Europe, et peut-être pour
de ce que sera la relation
Russie demain au reste
du monde dépendra probablement
- Oui. Vous disiez que c'est un
peu une répétition, aujourd'huià
fait en Géorgie. Plusieurs
analystes craignent justement
qu'il ne s'arrête pas àe que vo,
vous pensez que ce serait
possible qu'il refasse la même
chose en Géorgie?rois que ça déd
beaucoup de l'issue de cet
guerre. Ce que l'on voit,
c'est ce que certains expeires ,
c'est-à-dire
de conflit, les plus forts
s'affaiblissent,dure, et les pls
se renforcent. E
que l'on voit à l'oeuvre,
et je donner l'issue de ce conf,
mais que de l'issue de ce beaucp
l'avenir de tous nos pays qui
sont au pourtour de la Russie
et pas seulement ceux qui sont
- Vous avez officiellement
réitéré votre demande d'adhésion
à l'Europe. Est-ce que.oi c'estt
pour vous et jus
prête à aller, jusqu'où
la Géorgie est prête à allerpout
ce qui vous attend, en fait,
on sait que vous pouvez
déclencher encore une colèrede !
- Le choix de la Géorgie
pour l'Europe, il ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui, il date de bien
avant la Russie. Il a été
réitéré au moment ou la Gé
a retrouvé son indépendance
en 1918, puis en 91,
et aujourd'hui, il est inscrit
dans notre Constitution
et il est soutenu par 80 %
de la population. Donc,
c'est un choix existentiel.
Nous n'avons pas
perspective. Nous sommes,
par nos valeurs et par notre
situation géopolitique,
nous surope
et c'est notre avenir. Donc,
ce n'est pas quelque chose que
Poutine ou quelqu'un d'autre
peut d place.
- Hmm... Est-ce que vous avezest
en fait suffisamment,
que l'Occident est à la hauteur
des attentes avec l'Ukraine?
Parce qu'en Géorgie, en 2008,
on a un peu laissé faire
Vladimir Poutine.
- C'.
À plusieurs reprises, l'Europe,
l'Occident n'a pas été réactif.
On a trop pris en compte,
rratif russe,
quand il y avait des
provocations autour d'eux,
qu'ils ne faisaient que céder
, répondre.
Et on a essayé d'être
complaisants en espérant apaiser
la Russie. Et cette politique
d'apaisement n'a pas fonctionné,
elle n'a fait qu'encourager,
et la conséquence, c'est
aujourd'hui, c'est l'Ukraine.
Et je crois qu'aujourd'hui,
l'Ukraine a réussi ce miracle
de dessiller les yeux
de l'Occident, de montrer
où est la véritable provocation,
où est la véritable agression,
et de munir, en se faisant,
les Européens au
les Européens et les Américains,
et le continent américain.
Et je sais qu'au Canada,
il y a beaucoup
Ukrainiens qui pensent
aujourd'hui à leur patrie.
Et je voudrais leur dire
qu'ils peuvent être très fiersr.
- Oui. Mais jusqu'où,
vous pensez? Combien de temps
vous pensez que ces Ukrainienste
machine?
- Eh bien, je crois que personne
n'aurait pu dire, au débutdu cou
trois semaines. Les calculs des
experts, y compris américains,
je crois que c'était troisjourse
trois semaines, non seulement
ils ont tenu, mais la Russie
en est réduite aujourd'hui
à demander des armes
et des rations alimentaires
pour ses soldats à la Chine.
Alors, je crois qu'on peut
se dire que tout est permis et
que personne ne peut aujourd'hui
faire des prédictions sur ce qui
va arriver. On ne peut que
soutenir l'Ukraine, que soutenir
les Ukrainiens aussi longtemps
qu'eux jugeront que
la diplomatie n'a pas donné
les résultats qu'ils peuvent
en attendre, et
ou un accord qui serait pour eux
acceptable.
- Parce que pour vous,
il va aller jusqu'au bout,
Vladimir Poutine, en Ukraine?
- Malheureusement, moi,
je ne sais pas jusqu'où va aller
Vladimir Poutine. Probablement
qu'il ira jusqu'où il pe
aller. Et où il peut aller,
ça va dépendre des Ukrainiens,
du soutien qu'ils vont recevoir
de l'extérieur,
qu'ils reçoivent de l'extérieur.
C'est ça qui fait le rapport
des forces et c'est le rapport
des fo
si la diplomatie, ensuite,
peut prendre le relais
et obtenir un accord qui soit
un vra'hui,'hui,'hui,'hui,'hui,,
je ne sais pas si la Russie est
prête à un compromis.
- Très bien, Madame
oup
d'avoir pris ces quelques
minutes avec nous. C'est très
éclairant. Merci.